SUBCOMMITTEE. OF THE TRUTH
DONALD. MISTER RICHARD AGAIN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB FORTY EIGHT PLACES
OF FIFTEEN TO THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR PRESCHOOL THROUGH HIGHER
EDUCATION BOND ON THE MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY ABOUT. WHEN I
LEFT THE ASSEMBLY EIGHTY FORTY
EIGHT WAS KEY THROUGH.
UNFORTUNATELY BOND TOTALLY
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FOLLOWING BILLS. AB FORTY EIGHT
WITH ALL THAT TO HIGHER
EDUCATION I MAGICALLY AB SEVEN
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ADDED
USED TO USE YOU TO WITH DOLLAR
AMOUNT IS AS FOLLOWS. NINE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR PRESCHOOL
THROUGH TWELFTH TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE CSU. SYSTEM AND TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THE
BILL PRIORITIZES FUNDING FOR UC
AND CSU PROJECTS THAT ADDRESS
FIRE AND SAFETY SEISMIC AND
CRITICAL DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ISSUES AND REQUIRES UC AND CSU.
TO ADOPT A FIVE YEAR AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING PLAN. ON THE
CAGE WALL SIDE THE BILL MAKES A
NUMBER OF CHANGES TO THE SCHOOL
FACILITY PROGRAMS INCLUDING.
INCREASING THE STATE'S MATCH
FOR LOW WELL DISTRICTS AND
DISTRICT FROM HIGHER
PERCENTAGES OF LOW INCOME
FOSTER CARE AND E. L. STUDENTS.
ALLOWING STATE BOND FUNDS TO BE
USED FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
PRESCHOOL CLASSROOMS CLASSROOMS
KITCHEN AND SPACE FOR
COUNSELORS AND NURSES.
ADJUSTING THE CAP ON LOCAL
BONNIE TO AUGMENT SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
ABILITY TO RAISE LOCAL FUNDS.
AND UNTIL JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THIS BILL WAYS
SCHOOL IMPACT FEES FOR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROJECTS LOCATED
WITHIN A HALF MILE OF A TRANSIT
STOP AND REDUCES SCHOOL IMPACT
FEES. BY 20% FOR OTHER MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROJECTS THE
BILL ALSO SUSPENDS LEVEL THREE
FOR THE THREAT LEVEL THREE FEES
AND TILL JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT YET THE EFFORT
THERE IS JUST FOR HOUSING
OBVIOUSLY MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROJECTS. FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY PURPOSES THE
BILL REQUIRES SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
CHARTER SCHOOLS UC AND CSU TO
CONDUCT A PUBLIC HEARING AND
THEN AUDIT. AND POST PROJECT
AND AUDIT POST PROJECT AN AUDIT.
INFORMATION ON THEIR WEBSITES
THE NEED IS GREAT. BOB TWELVE
FUNDS FROM PROPOSITION FIFTY
ONE PASSED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
ARE ALREADY EXHAUSTED WITH OVER
A HUNDRED MILLION ALREADY ON A
WAITING LIST FUNDS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WOULD BE
EXHAUSTED IF THEY WERE ALLOWED
TO BE ALLOCATED FOR A MISTER
TERRY TRYING TO BACK TO YOU
THIS IS A GOOD BOND THAT SERVES
ALL STUDENTS PRESCHOOL THROUGH.
THROUGH THE UNIVERSITY AND- I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
TERM MEMBERS MARK MCDONALD ON
THE HALF OF THE- GERALDO FOR
HEALTHY AS A KERN ST VERMENTINO
SAN FRANCISCO YUBA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT ALL IN SUPPORT.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OF IDENTIFIED A TEN
YEAR SPENDING HALF OF FORTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS THEY CAN'T BE
BREACHED BY LOCAL BONDS ALONE
AND WHAT WE HAVE WITH THE STATE
PROGRAM IS A GOOD STATE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP THAT ENABLES US TO
MEET THE NEEDS. OF ALL OUR
FACILITIES THAT ARE IN SEISMIC
DISTRESS OPERATOR CTT
FACILITIES TO SERVE OUR
VETERANS AND OUR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS THIS IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AS THE MEMBER SAD AS
ALL LOWER BALL MONTHS I'VE BEEN
EXHAUSTED YOUR SPENDING PLAN OF
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS. WE.
WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SEVERE MEMBERS
JASON WORKING ON THE AFTER
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA OF
PROBABLY BEARD SITE AND STOCKS.
FORTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA HAS A
FIVE YEAR. THAT IDENTIFIES FOUR
EIGHT BILLION IN STATE OR
BELIEVE IN UNIVERSITY WE HAVE
SOME THE COLOR YOU FOR MY
COLLEAGUES. THE MOBILE WORLD
THE SIDE EFFECTS BY STATE THE
FRIENDLINESS AND SO FORTH WE'RE
VERY AGAIN THE INCLUSION OF YOU
SEE THIS BOND ONE THING. CENTER
GLAZER CANCELING BUT- BEFORE.
AND OTHER WITNESSES OF THEY
WOULD JUST GIVE THEIR NAME.
OKAY. INCLUDING FRAZIER
. SB SIX
SUPPORT. EVERY UPON THE HOUSE
OF. THE FACT THAT I'M PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S THAT THE- AND
VALLEY EDUCATION. ACTUALLY
WATER WOULD NOT HAPPEN THE
NORTH KOREANS HAVE. AND NOW.
THE CALIFORNIA RECALL INSURANCE
WAS HEARING. FROM SUPPORT THIS
BILL YOU'RE LIKE A BABY
AUTHORED. HELP MAKE THIS A
REALITY FOR ASSISTANCE. BOB AT
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION OF ONE. BY JUST
REPRESENTING HEALTH. OFFICIALS
AS WELL AS THE. YOUR MEMBERS AS
OF THE OTHER HAVE THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL FROM SUPPORT. MEMBERS
BRIAN I WAS. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WE'LL
PAUSE FOR A MOMENT AND TAKE
ROLE MEDINA PRESIDENT. SO I
THINK WE ARE AROUND A LOT. JUNE
GABRIEL IRWIN KILEY LEVINE LOW
PATTERSON HERE SANTIAGO WEBER
HERE. SO WE HAVE A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. AS A FIRST OR SECOND
ANY WITNESSES THAT IN
OPPOSITION. CA NINE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. I REALLY LIKE THAT
THANK YOU OFFER FOR THE HARD
WORK CITIES. IT INTO. ON MAKING
THIS BILL REALITY A LOT OF IF
GOOD VERY TIME CONSUMING AND I
THINK A LOT OF EFFORT THE BILL.
TOUCHES VIRTUALLY EVERY SEGMENT
OF EDUCATION I THINK IT'S NO
FOR THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AS I UNDERSTAND IT
FOR THE FIRST TIME IS INCLUDED
IN A POND AS YOUR AND HAVE THAT
SOMETHING TO FEEL GOOD ABOUT I
DO THINK THAT IT IS PROBLMATIC
THAT EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
BOB CALLED OUT SEPARATELY. IT
IT IT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT. IF
AT AS WE SHOULD THAT WE TREAT
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
AS A AS AS A PRIORITY IT SHOULD
HAVE ITS OWN SEPARATE CAR
ABOUT. RATHER THAN HAVING TO
FIGHT WITH K. THROUGH TWELVE
FOR ALLOCATION OF THOSE FUNDS
THAT SAID I THINK THIS IS A
VERY WORTH THE EFFORT IT'S A
WHERE THE BILL AND WE HAVE TO
MAKE. MOTIONS FOR. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CNN WE HAD A MOTION BY. DR
RUMBLE SECOND BY DOCTOR CHOI I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRING IN THE BILL FOR THE
PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR THIS
BILL WHICH HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED BOND
DOLLARS FOR PUBLIC CAMPUS
CAMPUSES WHICH WILL NOT ONLY
BENEFIT BENEFIT STUDENTS
FACULTY AND STAFF. BUT ALSO ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC VISIT THE
CAMPUS IS A COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SEE EXCUSE FOR YOU SEE SO WE
HAD A FIRST AND A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY BE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
CONCURRENT SEVEN AMENDMENTS
MEDINA HI MEDINA I'D CHOI. CHAU
AYE AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI
BLOOM HI BLOOM HI GABRIEL
GABRIEL I IRWIN WHEN I. KILEY
AYE KILEY AYE LEVINE. LOW LOW
AYE PATTERSON AYE PATTERSON ON
A SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I'D WEBER
WEBER HI. TWELVE ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT A WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR MAYBE A MINUTE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE SECOND. YES
.
RIGHT NOW ELEVEN ZERO. AB FORTY
EIGHT